قدري يقول نازحه افغانيه تقيم في منزل
صيني متهالك بمخيم بوليشينا في ضواحي
العاصمه كابول
اوضاعها المعيشيه المزريه زادها سوءا
انحصار فرص العمل
وشحم مصادر الرزق اغلب النمر
بالف دولار يجب ان اسدده في هذا الشتاء لم
نرى الحطب واقوى الثلج كانت حولنا ولا
نملك المال السنه الماضيه حصلنا على اعانه
الدقيق ثلاث مرات كان وضعنا جيدا اما هذه
السنه فلم يسال عنا احد لطالبان ولا
المؤسسه الدوليه
هذا المخيم واحد من ثمانيه واربعين مخيما
في كابول وحدها يسكنها قرابه عشره الاف
عائله اغلبها مخيمات من طين وتراب في
البدء كانت مجرد خيم وبعد ان طال بهم
المقام شيد النازحون هذه المنازل الطينيه
بجهود فرديه
فالنازحون في مخيمات كابول ينقسمون بين
لاجئين عادوا من باكستان وايران وبين من
نزحوا من مناطق الاشتباكات المسلحه منذ 20
عاما الى العاصمه كابول لكن ما زاد من
صعوبه اوضاعهم المعيشيه رفع المنظمات
الدوليه يدها عن المساعده منذ عده اشهر
اعتقد ان منع المراه من العمل في المؤسسات
الدوليه والحكوميه هو السبب الرئيسي لوقف
المساعدات الدوليه كنا نحصل على المساعدات
الغذائيه والاموال سابقا الان لا يوجد شيء
اكثر المتضررين من قطع المساعداتهم الصغر
حرموا من طفولتهم ومن حقهم في التعليم
والصحه
بالفعل ازدادت المشاكل الاقتصاديه في
افغانستان مقارنه بالسابق طالبنا المجتمع
الدولي بمساعده الهلال الاحمر الافغاني
حتى نتمكن من مساعده المحتاجين فهناك مئات
من مخيمات النازحين التي تحتاج الى
المساعدات
وخوفا من تفشي الامراض يعمد النازحون الى
حلق رؤوس اطفالهم خوفا من انتقال الامراض
وانتشارها بينهم وضعت الحرب في افغانستان
او زارها قبل اكثر من سنه ونصف لكن الحرب
على الفقر والعوز اشد واقسى ولا يبدو ان
الحكومه الافغانيه ستكون قادره على
مواجهتها
دون مساعده المجتمع الدولي ناصر شديد
الجزيره من احد مخيمات النزوح كابول